what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so it's return to our vs. series what I
want to do is talk about a battle that a
lot of you guys have been asking for in
the comments section for quite some time
now while most of our battles have
featured characters from Marvel taking
on characters from DC today we're going
to branch out a bit and use a character
from Image Comics and we're going to try
to answer the question who would win
spawn or the Ghost Rider Johnny Blaze
now what I think makes this such a
popular suggestion as well as an
intriguing battle is just how similar
these characters are in terms of both
what powers they have and how they got
them and so much like our previous
videos what we're going to do is we're
going to start with each character
breaking them down and then eventually
asking the question who would win so the
character that we know as spawn is
actually a guy named Al Simmons who was
a high-ranking assassin in the CIA now
once he began to question the CIA's
motivations and methods he was killed by
his partner to behest of his superiors
and so due to the fact that some of the
people that Al had killed during his
time with the CIA had actually been
innocent he ended up going to hell now
while he was there
Al Simmons trades his soul to a demon
named mal bozhe for the opportunity to
see his wife again
however as part of the trade Al Simmons
unwittingly became a hell spawn which is
a super-powered demonic entity forced to
do the bidding of mal Bhoja in the war
between heaven and hell now spawn
himself derives some of his powers from
the use of a symbiotic suit known as k7
Leatha that feeds off the energy emitted
by his body which is made of a substance
called necro plasm as a result of this
spawn not only weighs in excess of 500
pounds but also possesses superhuman
strength speed and durability in
addition to this is symbiotic suit also
allows him to shape-shift
create shields and weapons out of his
body's necro plasm and gives him a
spider since like ability that allows
him to sense impending danger it's also
important to note that since spawn does
not technically have a human body he can
take an extreme amount of damage as he's
been able to survive being impaled
dismembered electrocuted and even
walking through the fires and lava of
hell and in fact it's been said that the
only way to kill spawn is to cut off his
head now in addition to these enhanced
abilities spawn can also perform various
feats of magic including generating
Hellfire
city and powerful energy blasts he's
also able to summon other Hellspawn as
well as in view other souls with
Hellspawn powers spawn also possesses
telekinetic and telepathic abilities
which he can use to influence the
thoughts behaviors of others he can also
fly teleport turn invisible things
through solid objects and stopped on and
so in essence spawn is one of the most
powerful beings that we've ever seen in
the history of comic books this is
compounded by the fact that one of his
more unique abilities allows him to
summon the souls of all the people and
individuals ever hurt and allow those
souls to tear the individual apart
furthermore spawn has managed to trap
both God and Satan in their own pocket
dimensions and has demonstrated a
reality-warping ability after his power
level was elevated to being even with
the divine entities as he managed to
reform the earth to his own liking and
so what I want to do is actually want to
move away from spawn for a second and
I'm going to focus on Johnny Blaze now
much like spawn Ghost Rider also owes
his powers to a deal that he made with a
demonic force originally Johnny Blaze
was a stunt cyclist his adoptive father
was diagnosed with terminal cancer and
so in order to prevent his father's
death blaze sold his soul to the demon
Mephisto who did cure his father's
cancer but would eventually die due to a
motorcycle stunt gone wrong and so
because Mephisto was unable to claim
Johnny's soul due to the power of love
that Johnny held for his girlfriend
Roxanne he ended up getting revenge on
Johnny by bonding him to a demon known
as xerath os-- and so as a result johnny
was forced to become the Ghost Rider and
was bound to hunt down evil Souls and
return them to hell now as the Ghost
Rider Johnny receives several powers and
I have a video on the powers of the
various ghost riders including Johnny
Blaze if you feel like fine to watch it
but for the sake of this video we're
going to run over these real quick
siblings that we have them so that they
make sense now again much like spawn
Ghost Rider has superhuman strength
reflexes and durability he's also able
to create and manipulate Hellfire a
flame that can burn not only flesh but
can also sense the souls of his victims
and the most notable manifestation of
his ability is the motorcycle Johnny
rides which is made completely of
Hellfire and is able to travel at super
speeds and even travel at vertical
surfaces he also uses Hellfire to
transform an ordinary chain into a
dangerous weapon and can also project
Hellfire itself at his opponents and so
just to show you how powerful Hellfire
is Johnny Blaze has used Hellfire
against Iron Man
dr. doom and was able to use Hellfire to
penetrate both of their armors and Han
them and is used it effectively against
the Hulk and Lucifer now another power
that Ghost Rider possesses is the
penance stare which allows him to force
his victim to relive all of the harm
they've ever done to another person and
experience it as both mental anguish and
physical pain the penance stare has
proven to be extremely effective and
allowed Ghost Rider to incapacitate
powerful opponents like dr. strange and
dr. voodoo while the latter served a
sorcerer supreme and so now that we've
gone over each of these characters I
want to go through and see if we can
figure out a winner now honestly the
very thing that makes this battle so
intriguing is also what makes it so hard
to definitively declare a victor these
two characters are both extremely
powerful can take an insane amount of
damage can heal remarkably quickly and
command the very forces of hell what
also makes this especially difficult is
that many of the weapons each competitor
would use would more than likely not be
effective against the other namely the
Hellfire that both use as their primary
offensive weapon since I don't see how
either would be able to be harmed by it
that being said I think this battle
would actually be epic as each of these
would be a more than worthy competitor
for the other at the end of the day
though I would have to give this battle
to spawn for a couple of reasons first
on top of all of his powers spawn has
the edge and combat experience due to
his time in the Marine Corps in the CIA
which would give him a strategic and
tactical advantage more significant than
that however is that Ghost Rider's power
is actually limited by Johnny blazes
human body and Marvel Comics it has been
established that the power of the demon
zarathos would be great enough to do
incredible things like create explosions
so large that it harmed the Incredible
Hulk in his world breaker form as well
as defeat the physical manifestation of
Lucifer however when Johnny is in
control of Ghost Rider zarathos is
unable to reach his full potential with
that in mind this battle could actually
depend on whether Johnny Blaze decides
to let go of control of the Ghost Rider
which would make him harder to defeat
but which blaze has been hesitant to do
in the past however even in full
strength I'm not fully convinced the
Ghost Rider could actually defeat spawn
spawn possesses powers equal to the
level of a god he's banished God and
Satan from reality and if he's able to
do that I see no reason he could pretty
much do the same for Ghost Rider and for
that reason I'm giving the victory to
spawn now that's not to say that there
are no scenarios where Ghost Rider wins
maybe he finds a way to decapitate spawn
but as I said earlier I think spawns who
want to be resist
so most of growth fighters attacks due
to his control over hellfire and demonic
forces also I want to point out that
even though we focus on the Johnny Blaze
version of Ghost Rider
some of you might be wondering about
Marvel's new ghost rider Robby Reyes and
I think that in this case spawns victory
would be even more lopsided as Robby
Reyes has not really demonstrated his
power level in anywhere near close to
Johnny blazes level but with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and let me know down the comments
sections I'm sure a lot of you guys have
opinions let me know down in the
comments section what you guys think who
do you think would win between spawn and
Ghost Rider
not only that feel free to post comments
down below and let me know what videos
we should do on the vs. series in the
future and if you guys are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the subscribe button to become part of
the Rob core and make sure you guys trap
a like and I will catch you all later
peace